i
[Música]
ah
se han puesto a pensar cómo es que el
hombre en tan solo 200 años
ha cambiado prácticamente todas las
formas de movilidad que tienen 1860 el
hombre se estaba moviendo en una carreta
jalada por unos caballos o algunos otros
animales
en la versión 60
de la mano de lanzar strong estábamos
llegando a la luna y hoy en el 2021 al
parecer un hombre llamado león mosca
promete llevar al hombre a otro planeta
es increíble como personas que han
revolucionado la historia de la
humanidad como lo puedes ver informe
con la introducción de los automóviles y
cambiar prácticamente todo el sistema de
movilidad en el mundo o como el mismo de
lyon moscú con los cortes eléctricos o
los viajes
interplanetarios han podido cambiar
disruptiva mente la visión que tenemos
nosotros y la concepción de la humanidad
hay a lo que tienen estas personas en
particular
y yo en experiencia como servidor
público lo he notado con mi equipo de
trabajo
y si cuando grandes mentes le dicen a su
equipo de colaboración que debe de
existir un propósito y que todas las
personas en la organización tienen un
gran propósito es cuando los grandes
objetivos se pueden alcanzar
colin powell escribía en un libro muy
famoso acerca de los distintos
propósitos que tienen las grandes
empresas y las grandes organizaciones él
hablaba justamente del gran reto que fue
construir la elam park state en la
ciudad nueva york
que fue un gran edificio arquitectónico
de su época y que también cambió la
visión en los daños por estructura en la
vía norteamericana por muchos años en
ese entonces el ámbar state a los
arquitectos no tenían mucho presupuesto
competía con otro edificio que el
edificio chrysler y al final que
pudieron llegar a la meta y convertirse
en el rascacielos más alto
se les pregunto a las personas que
trabajaban ahí cuál era su propósito
recuerdo que colin powell en su libro
al sótano del ámbar state
y le pregunto a unas personas que
estaban ahí de limpieza cuál es tu
propósito de estar hoy trabajando en el
edificio más impresionante que tiene el
mundo
y una de las personas le contestaba mi
propósito es que este lugar se ve
espectacular por todas las personas que
vienen a visitarnos de todas partes del
mundo
aunque puede ser utilizado lo que le
contestó esta persona te das cuenta que
en cualquier organización y una persona
conoce perfectamente su propósito y su
objetivo
en cualquier lugar que él trabaje o
colabore la organización va a llegar a
buen puerto
y todas las organizaciones y lo vemos
como los gobiernos actuales en este 2021
nos daremos cuenta que muchas de las
personas que colaboran o que nos
gobiernan muchas veces carecen de un
gran propósito en la vida pública
nacional o en la vida pública
e internacional
en experiencia
secretario a la juventud de una entidad
federativa
o como asesor
una cámara
de la del sanar a la república me da
cuenta que lo más importante que tiene
un servidor público justamente es el
propósito así como cualquier líder de
cualquier organización lo más importante
que tiene es poder transmitirle a sus
colaboradores el propósito per se por el
cual se está trabajando todos los días
no es normal
que hoy nos encontramos en nuestra
realidad y nos pongamos a pensar en
países como los eeuu como lo es alemania
donde hay una palabra clave y un
propósito clave en el desarrollo de sus
políticas públicas y prácticamente en el
desarrollo de cualquier empresa o de
cualquier organización que existe en
nuestros países primermundistas
y esa palabra es innovación los
gobiernos las empresas las universidades
y muchas de las instituciones públicas y
privadas tienen a la innovación como el
centro clave
de todas las acciones que manejan
y es que si recordamos los grandes
avances en la historia de la humanidad
la innovación es la gasolina que nos
empuja a seguir creciendo a seguir
retándonos y a seguir creciendo en
nuestras ideas
al día de hoy estos países como los eeuu
corea del sur rusia no sólo son los que
tienen más patentes registradas sino que
también son los que tienen más personas
con doctorados o maestrías y esto se
debe pues a que los gobiernos invierten
mucho en la investigación pero sobre
todo invierten mucho en la innovación
si alguna vez se han preguntado cómo es
que el internet que ha cambiado la vida
a partir de 1998 1997 que entró en la
vida de todas las personas en el planeta
pues bueno fue porque un gobierno el
gobierno norteamericano le invierte una
fuerte cantidad de dinero a la
investigación y se detonó el internet
y es así como los países crecen muchas
veces no le queremos invertir a la
investigación muchas veces los líderes
no le quieren invertir a diferentes
proyectos que empujan las nuevas ideas
pues porque es rentable o políticamente
no puede ser muy rentable
hoy me gustaría platicarles del caso de
querétaro el lugar
donde yo vivo el lugar donde yo nací y
que ha sido todo un gusto y un
privilegio poder trabajar en el servicio
público por un estado que amo y que
estoy seguro es el mejor lugar para
vivir en mexico
querétaro hace 200 años
la primera empresa que llegó aquí a mi
estado una empresa de textil
200 años después hoy encontramos en
nuestra entidad la mentefactura que le
llamamos
tenemos los mayores centros de
investigación en toda la república
mexicana y también estamos trabajando
hoy como ninguna otra parte en méxico la
industria 4.0 donde a través de las
universidades se ofertan una gran gama
de carreras enfocadas justamente a la
industria 4.0 y diferentes empresas o
industrias como es la aeronáutica la
automotriz o la de datos que ya se
encuentran las sentadas en el listado y
esto se da un gran factor y regreso a la
palabra clave es la innovación los
gobiernos en querétaro le han decidido
apostar a políticas públicas que salten
un poco de la burocracia y que estén
concentradas en nuevas formas de hacer
gobierno
en experiencia durante los últimos años
hemos trabajado para las y los jóvenes
del estado de querétaro
es difícil hablar de juventud cuando
hablamos de política pública hablamos de
política
porque muchos de los políticos
ven a la juventud como un gran capital
político a un gran capital que los puede
llevar a ocupar puestos de elección
popular y no lo que lo que somos los
jóvenes hoy en méxico somos un gran
capital social
si nos damos cuenta de esto cuando un
gobernante hace política pública para el
grupo etario más grande de toda la de
todo el país nos damos cuenta las
grandes cosas que se pueden hacer
en querétaro y no vamos en política
pública haciendo un centro de contrabajo
y como emprendimiento lo llamamos núcleo
un lugar donde las ideas puedan tener
auge y donde muchas personas puedan
venir a trabajar en sus diferentes
proyectos impulsados por tres grandes
ramas la académica
el sector privado y el sector público
pero más allá de eso está política
pública ha hecho una gran comunidad de
personas donde hoy las ideas la
innovación y el emprendimiento es lo que
se respira en todas las paredes de este
lugar
y es verdad que no
se inventó el hilo negro en esta
política pública sino que simplemente se
empujó las ideas de las personas jóvenes
aquí en nuestro estado de querétaro lo
que hoy estamos buscando
es mantener un gran dinamismo en el
estado
empujado de lo más importante que tiene
cualquier comunidad que son las personas
jóvenes
recuerdo una vez ir a un centro de
investigación en juriquilla la
universidad nacional autonoma de mexico
donde se investiga justamente el genoma
humano
hay un equipo interdisciplinario de
aproximadamente 15 personas donde uno
puede decirlo haber
pero me comentaba la persona que me está
dando el recorrido que estas 15 personas
debían ser personas abajo de los 30 años
que debían de tener un doctorado y que
preferentemente hablaran más de 3
idiomas
este equipo era compuesto por jóvenes y
estaban estudiando las nuevas
innovaciones en torno al genoma humano y
él me comentaba algo me decía las
personas son sumamente creativas de sus
20 a sus 30 años y a veces no nos damos
cuenta la capacidad creativa que tenemos
a estas edades
es por eso que el equipo que estamos
formando aquí en el centro de
investigación tiene que necesariamente
están formado por jóvenes y es que
después de los 30 empezamos a tener un
poco de ideas más cuadradas y somos un
poco más reúnen test a cualquier otras
ideas es por eso que hemos de aprovechar
mucho cuando hablamos de política
pública las mentes de las personas
jóvenes la creatividad pero sobre todo
las grandes ideas que podemos tener hay
personas que lo entienden como este
centro de investigación de la unam y hay
personas a veces en la vida pública en
nuestro país que difícilmente van a
poder entender este tipo de cuestiones
hoy en querétaro se le está apostando a
la innovación pasamos pues esta fábrica
textil en hércules hasta grandes
clusters aeronáuticos en el municipio de
colon y próximamente estaremos por
lanzar el primer nanosatélite al espacio
y es todo porque aquí la comunidad que
es en su mayoría jóvenes le apuesta por
esta palabra de innovación
me he puesto a pensar si diferentes
gobiernos pudieran tener instituciones
dedicadas justamente a la innovación el
emprendimiento que sería de la política
pública en nuestro país que sería si se
tuvieran diferentes instituciones que
concentrarán el gasto grandes programas
y grandes infraestructuras
para buscar incentivar la innovación la
creatividad y las ideas de las personas
ya que decirlo claro porque en las
universidades en las escuelas muchas
veces no nos enseñan cosas tan
precisas o tan necesarias que
necesitamos cuando incursionamos en los
temas laborales que es como darse de
alta en el sat o como tal vez crear una
empresa
y es cuando el emprendedor se para
en la vida en la vida laboral y no sabe
ni siquiera cuál es el norte no sabe ni
siquiera cuál es el sur y es por eso que
muchos emprendimientos fracasa si
existieran brazos y grandes
instituciones que enseñaran y apoyarán
con programas sociales a la innovación y
el emprendimiento estoy completamente
convencido que viviríamos en otro país y
en otro entorno
yo le llamo la cultura de la innovación
y es que en estos años tan
trascendentales para la vida y la
humanidad
después de este 2020 y este 2021 estoy
convencido que tenemos grandes
herramientas a nuestro alcance hoy
cualquier persona puede emprender a
través de su teléfono celular y
prácticamente podemos comentarle al
mundo cualquier idea a través de las
distintas plataformas sociales
estamos en un punto medio donde estamos
a punto de transformar los diferentes
métodos de gobernanza que conocíamos
antes se dividía por países o es como lo
vivimos ahora con grandes territorios y
comunidades de 100 millones de personas
hasta 500 millones de personas en asia
pero ahora tenemos comunidades incluso
más grandes que son las comunidades
digitales
hoy hay un gran dilema de cómo se deben
regular estas comunidades hasta dónde
puede llegar la libre expresión o cómo o
qué limitaciones deben de tenerlo y eso
nos va a tocar a nosotros los jóvenes
tendremos que tener a la innovación y
esta cultura para poder enfrentar los
grandes desafíos que vamos a tener a
posteriori en los próximos años
para mí lo más valioso y lo más
importante que he vivido en el servicio
público pues definitivamente es tratar
de hacer las cosas de una distinta y
diferente manera siendo jóvenes nos
vamos a encontrar siempre a dos tipos de
personas en nuestros entornos laborales
y es muy importante identificarlas
porque si te dediques al gobierno así te
dediques a la iniciativa privada o así
estés emprendiendo y tocando las puertas
de muchas personas siempre encontrarás a
personas mayores que tú que tengan dos
tipos de visiones y no van a dejar
mentir
las primeras son personas mayores que
vas a llegar con ellos les vas a recibir
tus ideas y te van a decir
y las cosas no se hacen así tus ciudades
están equivocadas se ve que estás
empezando no tienes experiencia
la verdad es que solo que están tratando
de decir
estoy asustado por la preparación que
tienes
no quiero que vayas a quitar mi trabajo
con esa capacidad de ese talento y esas
nuevas ideas y verdaderamente lo único
que debemos hacer nosotros es alejar a
esas personas
porque lo más valioso que tenemos como
emprendedores como trabajadores siempre
serán las ideas que tenemos porque
entramos con otra diferente perspectiva
por la coyuntura en la que vivimos y
porque entramos con nuevas visiones a
los entornos a los cuales nos estamos
introduciendo
pero también vamos a encontrar otras
personas que les va a dar una curiosidad
intelectual muy grande de lo que estamos
haciendo recuerdo mucho cuando entré al
gobierno del estado que usaba diferentes
aplicaciones y diferentes herramientas
para tomar mis notas que había personas
que me preguntaban qué aplicación es esa
enseñamos usarla oye tú qué piensas
sobre este tema tú qué harías en esta
situación todas esas personas que tienen
ya un poco más de experiencia y que
tienen esa curiosidad intelectual que
hay que saber identificarla con esas
personas que debemos de tener
necesariamente cerca porque son las
personas que nos van a poder guiar y nos
van a poder orientar ya las otras
completamente dejarlas a un lado
estas personas nos van a incentivar la
capacidad innovadora que tengamos y las
otras simplemente no van a querer
cambiar
es por eso que a mí me encantaría
transmitir a través de este gran foro en
el que hoy estamos en esta gran
comunidad que hoy tenemos aquí y
decirles a todas las personas que
estamos en un momento muy coyuntural en
méxico en querétaro y en el mundo
la innovación será la pieza fundamental
para resolver los diferentes problemas y
retos que tenemos
hoy si nosotros exigimos instituciones
que crean en nuestras ideas que
incentiven el emprendimiento pero que
sobre todas las cosas nos dejen innovar
en cualquier situación vamos a poder
encontrar grandes soluciones y nuevos
métodos de participación
que nadie nos diga que no podemos hacer
las cosas y que nadie pare las ideas y
el talento que tenemos
núcleo
y esta política pública de la que se ha
hablado es el ejemplo perfecto sigamos
creando sigamos desarrollando pero sobre
todo sigamos teniendo buenas ideas y hay
muchas personas que seguirán
construyendo y tal vez no estarán
llevando a marte o estarán
revolucionando transformas del
pensamiento y las formas de hacer las
cosas y la gran pregunta es donde
estaremos nosotros muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah